it's one of the most highly anticipated
space missions in recent memory
after more than two decades of setbacks
and delays the james webb space
telescope is finally cleared for launch
and expectations at the space center in
french guiana are high
and i think i speak for everyone to say
that we're really excited to see it
launch and i think everyone's done
everything they can to make it a
successful launch as well
webb is the most powerful space
telescope ever built
its mission to peer back 13.5 billion
years ago to the early stages of our
universe
scientists say the potential for new
discoveries could upend everything we
know about our place in the cosmos we're
really trying to look further back in
time and you know examine how some of
those first galaxies formed we're trying
to rewrite some of the astronomy books
that exist right now
at the space museum in the city of peru
a new generation of astronomers
anxiously await liftoff
and the excitement is just as high for
aspiring scientists as it is for the
grown-ups who have been waiting for this
moment for years
i've been studying astronomy for 10
years i'm very excited about this
telescope so many questions will be
answered thanks to it i study exoplanets
those planets that orbit stars other
than our sun and looking at their
atmosphere we could find possible
evidence of extraterrestrial life
the webb space telescope represents a
collaborative effort by more than a
dozen countries and the work of
thousands of scientists and engineers
from all over the world
the fairing sitting atop of that aryan 5
rocket is housing the james webb space
telescope and those rocket boosters that
you see on the side of the spacecraft
have been filled with some 480 metric
tons of solid fuel propellant just
enough to blast off and send this
payload some one and a half million
miles away from earth
with the rocket now sitting on its
launch pad fingers are crossed and
collective breaths are being held for
weather conditions to be optimal on the
day of launch
manuel rapalo al jazeera peru french
guiana